it is cold yes we've had some pretty
chilly mornings really for the winter so
far but this is definitely going to be
one of the chilliest nice clear skies
that's allowing the warmth which wasn't
a whole lot of warmth yesterday to
escape and yesterday this is a great
video thank you michelle riley for
sharing it with us a little snow out
there on the east side she lives out
there by sam boyd stadium you can see
off in the distance and her puppy dogs
were out enjoying the unusual weather
aren't they cute one state inside very
smart puppy stayed indoors watching the
scene but it was chilly out there so
thanks michelle we had some great videos
some really beautiful photos of the snow
around
most mostly around the valley but even
out on the east side where you just saw
that video it was a mix of rain and snow
at times and sometimes just snow so
we've got some very cold temps below
freezing in henderson this morning 20's
at nellis
seven hills mountains edge you're in the
20s 30 degrees in summerland below
freezing centennial hills in the lakes
20 at red rock and single digits up at
kyle canyon below zero up in ely at
minus four 10 degrees in caliani 20's
for indian springs and prump at 24 you
had some nice snow yesterday as well
some good rain up in mesquite and we've
got some wind right now in lofland and
that's making low 40s feel more like 30s
this morning so thanks again for sharing
all your beautiful photos this one from
up in mesquite shane morris took a great
shot of the virgin mountains up there
and we made a slideshow if you'd like to
see them eight newsnow dot com you can
go and look at all the great photos we
did pick up some nice rain in areas but
most of the rain fell over in northwest
arizona where you could see up to a
third of an inch northeast of dolan
springs trace of rain officially that's
it four hundredths of an inch fell night
before last on the west side and six
inches of snow up at lee canyon oh
that's great snow we needed it so badly
this system brought us a lot of clouds
and wind yesterday along with those
brief showers at times snow focusing on
the mountains and over into arizona utah
it's all gone now 53 for our high today
that's up from yesterday's 40s and it's
going to take us a while to get back to
some normal mid 60s barely on sunday
with some breezes friday saturday next
week 70's as we roll into march might
even make it up to 80 degrees on
wednesday wow what a change